what what brought about the hero code
you know i think it really kind of came
back to make your bed i mean i'm always
just like you are jocko you know people
are always asking me
you know uh you know kind of give us
more lessons that sort of thing but
but people were asking me okay tell me
who your heroes are
um and and the hero code it's not about
me i mean it's through my eyes but it's
about people that i met or encountered
along the way
and it is about the qualities that they
had
um and i actually when i first started
it
um i thought you know what is a hero i
mean
we kind of intuitively know what a hero
is but i pulled up the textbook
definition
and it was actually pretty good the
textbook definition says a hero is
someone we admire
for their noble qualities and i like
this idea of their
noble qualities doesn't mean they're
perfect but they have noble qualities
certainly
at a point in time when when they need
them so the first story is about courage
and winston churchill said something
like
you know courage is the most important
of all qualities because it guarantees
all the rest
so you know you're not going to have
anything else unless you first have
courage and the first story is about
ashley white who was
unfortunately killed in afghanistan and
her remarkable courage but i go through
the book with these
these stories of these people that i
think have the right qualities the
courage and humility and sacrifice and
perseverance and
in this sense of duty and you read a
little bit on the sense of humor
uh i mean frankly and i tell the story
about
being at udt 11 but of course i saw that
sense of humor
in the hospitals and this is when it
really resonated with me back to the
the infantryman who said you know you
should have seen the other guy i mean
how many times did i
that i give some guy you know the kind
of good-natured banner you say man you
look like [ __ ]
that was always a standard comeback you
should see the other guy
uh and of course that was their way of
saying hey i may have lost an arm or a
leg but they haven't beaten me
i can still laugh about this and so you
know and then the last one is on
forgiveness
and you talk about you know what
missions went south well this is one
that went really south on us
uh and it was a uh we were going after a
bad guy
in gardez uh had some soldiers on target
uh we thought the bad guy was in the
compound
guys got up on the on the walls uh
snipers looking down in
somebody comes out with an ak-47 he gets
shot another guy
in a doorway picks up an ak-47
the the soldier automatic weapon
shoots him but in shooting him rounds go
through him
and unbeknownst killed a number of women
on the other side
and so when the action dies down they
get on target
uh they can't figure out why the the
women by the time we get in there
they are bound and uh and so frankly
initially we thought maybe it was honor
killing
but of course we didn't uh it sounds
crazy but we just didn't understand at
the time that
you know they bound them up so that they
the jaws didn't open and other things
and
so it took us a while to really
understand what's going on but then what
we realized as we did the investigation
was
a one the two guys with the ak-47s
turned out to be
afghan policemen and the women were
innocent bystanders
uh that we had unfortunately killed i
mean it was it was the war of all my
time it was the worst
you know kind of uh civilian casualty
incident
um that i'd seen and we'd had some bad
ones but none quite as bad as that
and i realized hey at the end of the day
i mean
it's back on me and so i went down to
apologize
to the father and i remember i linked up
with some afghan soldiers and and one
other army guy
and we went into this town in gardez and
of course there are hundreds of
angry afghans um
but you got an obligation you know so i
i sat down in this
uh kind of city hall for lack of a
better term with about 200 afghans
seated there and
and and i apologize to the father and i
remember before i did it i
had talked to my afghan counterpart
general saleem
and i said what do i say to this guy i
mean we killed his sons and
and a daughter what do you say to a guy
like that and salim looked at me and he
kind of
cocked his head and he said oh he will
forgive you
i said so i don't know he goes oh no he
will he will forgive you
and i said well with all due respect
slain and he said he's a good muslim he
will forgive you
and he said look he said the thing about
forgiveness
is it not only relieves your burden
it will relieve his burden as well it
will take away his
anger and it will if he forgives you
and i thought man that that's that's a
stretch but i got there and
sat down with the father and i
apologized to him and and i could see
the look in his eye and and
and they forgave me and this idea of
forgiveness particularly today
you know it seems like everybody today
gets easily offended
um you know everybody gets slighted and
they want to hold on to that
anger they don't want to forgive people
for whatever that slight was
because the anger empowers them to be
mad
it empowers them to fight back and they
feel like if they let that anger go if
they forgive that individual
then they don't get to be the person
that holds the power
and i think that's just absolutely the
wrong way to approach it i mean
the whole thing about forgiveness i tell
the story about there about the white
supremacist dylan roof that killed all
the people at the
the baptist church and the families went
up
one by one and said i forgive you i
forgive you and the point was
they were not going to they were not
going to hold on to that anger they were
not going to kind of bear that burden
um so today as we look at society and we
we wonder
why everybody gets so offended i mean i
i would offer
uh take the opportunity to to try to
forgive the people that
offend you i mean some of them are big
offenses some of them are little ones
but i think as a society we can we can
do a little better than
and every single slide every single you
know
misstep somebody takes you don't have to
hold on to that anger you don't have to
fight back you can forgive people
well it takes a lot more strength to
forgive someone than it does to hold a
grudge
it absolutely does i i often worry to
worry
because you know sometimes we have whole
sections of society or countries
or peoples that that have
a grudge and you know i i look at it as
two parts like
you need one one side needs to say i'm
sorry and the other side needs to
forgive
and it's very difficult to get two human
beings just just two human beings to do
that
and when you have you know a collective
lot of grievances from two different
opposing sides
we have a hard time making that progress